خطوه بعد خطوه يمضي الاكراد على اختلاف
مشاربهم في العراق وسوريا نحو توسيع
سيطرتهم وبسط نفوذهم على مناطق متن ع
القوميات واغلبها متنازع عليه هكذا كان
الامر في مدينه كركوك العراقيه التي صوت
مجلس محافظتها لصالح رفع علم كردستان على
دوائرها الرسميه اما في سوريا فقد وضعت
القوات الكرديه يدها على مطار طبق العسكري
مؤكده ان محطتها القادمه ستكون الرقه
وتوسع يستمر بدعم امريكي ويثير قلقا
اقليميا متصاعدا ازاءه خاصه لدى الجاره
تركيا تابعوا هذا التقرير للزميل فتحي
اسماعيل قبل ان نبدا
النقاش على وقع التحركات العسكريه
المتسارعه باتجاه مدينه الرقه السوريه
استعدادا لساعه الصفر يحقق اكراد سوريا
مزيدا من المكاسب الميدانيه مستفيدين من
دعم التحالف الدولي وخاصه الاسناد
الامريكي فما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المشكله اساسا من وحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه وقليل من العرب تمكنت
من السيطره على مطار مدينه الطبقه وعده
مواقع كانت بيد تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
فيما تتواصل معارك ضاريه بين الطرفين
تحاول من خلالها القوات الكرديه دخول
المدينه الواقعه على بعد نحو 40 كيلومترا
من الرقه مدينه الطبقه وغيرها ما هي الا
جبهات عابره ومؤقته فالهدف هو الرقه عاصمه
تنظيم الدوله ومع اقتراب ذلك الهجوم
المفترض وسيطره قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
على معظم مساحه الريف الشرقي للرقه ارتفعت
في الاوساط الكرديه نبره الحديث عن الحكم
الذاتي والاداره المحليه ما قد يؤشر الى
ان الاكراد قد لا يكتفون بعد الان بان
يكونوا مجرد راس حربه في الحرب على
التنظيم كما حدث سابقا في عين العرب
كوباني وتل الابيض ومنبج وغيرها وانما ان
يصبحوا بعد معركه الرقه المرتقبه الرقم
الصعب في المشهد السوري
عامه يعني ذلك من ضمن ما يعنيه تحويل
المكاسب العسكريه الى انجازات سياسيه
القيادي الكردي السوري صالح مسلم رئيس حزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي توقع ان تنظم مدينه
الرقه الى نظام حكم لام مركزي بعد انتزاع
السيطره عليها من تنظيم الدوله
فهل تصبح عاصمه التنظيم عاصمه لكيان كردي
مع ان غالبيه سكان الرقه هم من العرب
مقارنه بالوجود النسبي الكردي فيها وحتى
تلك المناطق التي سبق
لاكرام الثوره وانشا فيها ادارات محليه
فانهم لا يشكلون فيها سوى اغلبيه نسبيه لا
مطلقه لكن يبدو ان المطامح الكرديه سابق
الزمن للاستفاده القصوى من مرحله يراها
الكرد مؤات لا في سوريا وحسب وانما في
المنطقه برمتها ففي كركوك العراقيه الغنيه
بالنفط والمتنازع عليها قرر مجلس المحافظه
ذو الاغلبيه الكرديه ورغم رفض بقيه اعضائه
العرب والتركمان قرر رفع العلم الكردي في
كل المقرات الرسميه بجوار العلم العراقي
في خطوه كانت الامم المتحده قد حذرت من
عواقبها على التعايش السلمي في البلاد
والخطوه اثارت ايضا غضب تركيا التي
اعتبرتها تجاوزا لدستور العراق واكثر من
ذلك ربما عزز التصرف الكردي في كركوك
هواجس انقره القديمه من مثل تلك المساعي
ولا سما فيما يجري الترتيب له الان في
الشمال
السوري للحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من اربيل الدكتور ازاد علي مدير مركزي
روداو للدراسات ومن اسطنبول رسول توسون
النائب السابق في حزب العداله والتنميه
ومن لندن بسام جعاره الكاتب والاعلامي
السوري المعارض نبدا من اربيل والدكتور
ازاد علي يعني يبدو الاكراد كما يرى البعض
في سباق محموم لفرض ما وصف بامر واقع في
مناطق هي في الاصل متنازع عليها وليسوا
الغالبيه فيها
لماذا
بدايه مساء الخير مساء النور لك ولضيفك
ولجميع المشاهدين الكرام
الحقيقه لا المس اي سباقا ولا اي حراكا
محموما سوى الخطاب الغير موضوعي للاسف
التي تصاغ بها بعض
تقارير قناتكم الكريمه وخاصه هذا التقرير
الذي اعتمد على مصطلحات غير موضوعيه
ومصطلحات فيها الكثير من الاستفزاز واللام
مهنيه كالسي طره والتحكم والتمدد والى
اخره اختي
الكريمه لا يمكن ان نفصل اي معركه او اي
خطوه حاليه عن سياقاتها الموضوعيه وعن
جذورها التاريخيه ف القضيه الكرديه قضيه
متكامله ومتسلسله لم تظهر اليوم امس هي
ليست مع الوجود الامريكي في المنطقه بعد
عام 2003 ولا هي مع داعش ولكن التغطيه
الاعلاميه وما تطلب من مقاومه ل الكرد
والقوات الكرديه في الدفاع عن انفسهم وفي
الدفاع عن كثير من اجزاء العراق
وسوريا وعن تلك المناطق التي عرفتموها
بانها متنازع عليها او انها حقيقه مناطق
قد اقتطعت من مناطق كرديه وقد عانت مما
عانت من التغيير الديموغرافي والحرمان
والحروب الاباده فدماء الكردي لم تجف منذ
قرون عديده في الدفاع عن حقوقهم ووجودهم
وما زالت هنالك
الالاف ما زال هنالك الالاف من السبايا
ومن الاطفال الكرد ومن النساء الكرد
بيد تنظيم داعش الارهابي الذي لم ياتي من
فراغ وانما له تداخل
وتشابك وهو تنظيم ذو علاقه جدليه مع
التنظيمات
وال والحكومات
العنصريه العروبيه البعثيه السابقه دعنا
نتحول السيد بسام جعاره من لندن سيد بسام
سمعت ما ذكره ضيفنا من اربيل هو يشكك في
كل ما جاء ليس في تقريرنا فقط لكن هذه
مصطلحات متداوله على نطاق واسع لا سيطره
كما يقول ولا تمدد ولا تحكم ولا وجود
لمناطق متنازع عليها هو يقول بانها اقتطعت
من مناطق كرديه مما الخشيه
اذا يعني اسمحي لي اقول اولا هو يتحدث عن
داعش عندما جاء صالح مسلم الى سوريا جاء
في ايار 2011 ولم يكن هناك داعش وعندما
جاء ارجان الى سوريا في عام
1979 نعرف تماما ما الذي جرى في مؤتمره
الاول عام 81 ومؤتمر الثاني عام 82 هذا
التنظيم ولد في رحم المخابرات السوريه
وعندما جاء صالح مسلم اراد النظام ان
يستعين به لاعطاء طابع طائفي سني للثوره
السوريه وايضا لكي يبعد الاخوه الاكراد
المناصرين للثوره عن الثوره تحول صالح
مسلم وحزبه الى عصا هذا الحزب هو الجناح
السوري لحزب العمال الكردستاني ولا اريد
ان ادخل في تفاصيل طائفيه لاقول مثلا ان
ان ثلاث ارباع قياداته من العلويين استطيع
ان اسمي من زوجه اجدان السابقه الى
قياداته اللاحقه من جميل بايك الى حيدر
علي حيدر الى الى البقيه اللي بتقوله بكل
وضوح عندما جرى ما جرى في سوريا لم يكن
هناك داعش ولا جبه النصره الاكراد يتحدثون
منذ زمن طويل عن تطلعهم لاقامه دوله تصل
الى البحر يعني على امتداد اكثر من 900 م
من المثلث السوري التركي العراقي الى
البحر المتوسط والذي جرى الان هم دائما
ياخذون مغامرات خاصره من جمهوريه مهاباد
التي خذلها السوفيت الى اتفاق شاه ايران
مع صدام حسين عام ال 75 ودائما يدفع
الاكراد الثمن غاليا طبعا ثمن مغامراتهم
هم يتحدثون عن مناطق كرديه انا بدي اسال
هل يوجد 100 الا كردي في الرقه مثلا هل
يوجد الف كردي في منبج لا يوجد على
الاطلاق هم يعتقدون حتى في الجزيره انا
بدي اقول كلام واضح وصريح نسبه العرب اكبر
معظم الاكراد هاجروا خلال السنوات الماضيه
حتى قبل الثوره الى اوروبا وكانت السويد
والمانيا وهولندا تحتضنهم وهم اقليه معظم
الذين يقاتلون الان هم من الاتراك ومن
الاكراد العراقيين قله صغيره تقاتل مع حزب
العمال يعني اللي بدي اقوله بكل مضوع وضح
سيد وضح سيد بس ساعود اليك دعنا نستطلع
وجهه نظر تركيا وهي معنيه بهذا الموضوع مع
السيد رسول طوسون تركيا كما ذكرنا كان لها
رد فعل مباشر هي التي وصفت خطوه رفع العلم
الكردي في كركوك بانها خطوه احاديه وقالت
بانها معارضه للدستور هذه الخطوه التي
استفزت الاتراك
باعتقادك الى اي مدى يمكن
بالفعل ان تكرس ما يود الاكراد ان يحققوه
كما ذكر سيد بسام الحلم ال ال كردي الاكبر
باقامه دولتهم هل تاتت الظروف المواتيه
لذلك
باعتقادك بدايه يجب التمييز بين اداره
اقليم الكردستاني في شمال العراق وبين
تنظيم بياده الارهابي تنظيم بياده
الارهابي ينتمي الى حزب الامال الكردستاني
الارهابي وله وليس له اي شرعيه اما حكومه
اقليم كردستان العراقيه هذه لها شرعيه يجب
ان نميز بينهما وكذلك يجب ان نميز بين
الاكراد والتنظيمات
الارهابيه
فعندما تدين تركيا العمليات الارهابيه
لتنظيم فيده
وفكاكه الارهابي البعض يظن ان تركيا تدين
الاكرات و وتحرم وتحصر وتمنع الاكراد من
حقوقها لا الاكراد في في تركيا يتمتعون
بكل ما يتمتع الاتراك هذه نقطه اما النقطه
الثانيه بخصوص رفع العلم
لاقليم كردستان في الحقيقه هذا تصرف
استفزازي بادرت اليه جماعه طالباني حزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي الكردستاني وسكت للاسف
اقليم كردستان الطرف برزاني ف تركيا تحذر
الاطراف وتحذر
[موسيقى]
ايضا الذين
رفعوا علم اقليم
كردستان
من اذكاء الفتنه العنصريه لان ماذا عن
تخوفات التركيه نود ان نفهم
معك عناصر تتخوف تركيا من مجمل هذه
التحركات سواء التي شاهدناها في اقليم
كركوك او حتى ما يحدث على الاراضي
السوريه رفع رف رف رفع العلم الاقليمي في
كركوك التي لم يجرى استفتاء كما جاء في
الماده 140 من الدستور العراقي كان
المفروض ان يقرر المواطنين جعل المحافظه
اقليما محافظه اخرى اقليما فهذا الاستفتاء
لم يتم فلذلك
المنطقه يعني لم ليس هناك اتفاق منازع
عليها لذلك رفع العلم الكردستاني يستفز
اتراك والعرب وغيرهم من العناصر تركيا
تحذر الاطراف من اذكاء الفتنه اثاره
الفتنه تركيا
تهتم يعني في هذه
بهذه بهذه النقطه تركيا تقف الى جوار
الحكومه المركزيه البغداديه اذ المتحدث
بالحكومه البغداديه يوم الخميس اعلن انه
لا يجوز رفع علم اي اي علم في كركوك لان
الدستور لا يسمح له فهناك مختل فيها كما
تعرفون سيد رسول نعم ساعود اليك دعني
اتحول مره اخرى للدكتور ازاد علي سمعت
دكتور ازاد من الواضح ان هناك تخوفات ومن
عده اطراف من هذه الخطوات الكرديه سواء في
العراق او حتى في سوريا الا تخشون من
تبعات هذه الخطوات ام ان الاكراد كما يقول
البعض يستندون الى موقف قوي داعم لهم من
قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا ما
يشجعهم في الواقع على المضي قدما في هذا
الاتجاه
اختي الفاضله ينبغي ان لا نخلط بين
السياسات الحزبيه كما تحدث ضيفك من
اسطنبول
و بين نزعات انتقاميه لا لا اود لها ان
تظهر في خطاب الاخ
بسام ولا اي قيادي او معارض سوري اخر فلغت
الحوار ولغه التفاهم والبحث عن المشتركات
تلزمنا اكثر في هذه المرحله لاننا في
مرحله حرب ينبغي ان نسعى جميعا لاطفاء نار
الحربي واشعال شموع السلام الاكراد اذا
تحدثنا بهذا المجمل لا يمكن ان نصل خلال
ساعات ل شرح تفاصيل ما نناقشه ولكن في
سياق رفع العلم في مدينه كركوك التي هي من
المعروف تاريخيا وحسب كل المراجع والمصادر
العربيه الاسلاميه منذ الاف السنين
و ل اللي لكل من اطلع ولو قليلا على
التاريخ العربي الاسلامي انها منطقه منطقه
شهرزور المشهوره الكرديه التاريخيه
وهلا نريد الحديث في التاريخ
عف دكتور از لا نريد الحديث عن تاريخ
حدثني عن الان حدثني عن الرقه والمشاريع
الكرديه
ن تتحول الى عاصمه كرديه وكيان منفصل في
الشمال
السور يا اختي انتم تفترض انتم تفترض
افتراضات وبهذه الافتراضات تساهمون في خلط
الاوراق
وفي عدم اتاحه الفرصه للتفاهم ليس هنالك
مشاريع وليس هنالك غزوات الاكراد في اربير
يمارسون الديمقراطيه رفعوا العلم موضوع
عراقي وموضوع كربي داخلي
وا هم سيجدون حلا لها وفي سوريا ليس هنالك
علم كردي حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي ليس حزبا
ارهابيا انما الذهنيه لبعض الحكام الاتراك
هي ذهنيه استعماريه دكتاتوريه لا تجد في
الاخر الا عدوا ف ف فهم يدافعون عن
مناطقهم لهم مشروع حزبي هم حزب يساري معدل
يختلفون معنا ومعكم ومع الاخرين في عده
نقاط اذا لا رغبه لدى الاكراد في حكم ذاتي
ولا حتى اداره محليه في تلك المناطق ذلك
ما نفهمه منك يعني اتحول لسيد بسام جعار
ان كان هذا فعلا ما تقوله لا لا لا لا لا
لا لا لا لا تستقي ارجوك الاكراد الاكراد
اذا حكينا بالعموميات الاكراد لا يغامرون
الاكراد يطالبون بحقوقهم هم شعب مظلوم شعب
واضح دعني اتحول بفكرتك اذا ل السيد بسام
السيد بسام جعار فقط لان الوقت يداهمنا
سيد بسام و وضحت وجهه نظرك سيد بسام ان
كنت تسمعني نود ان نعرف من كيف تجلت مظاهر
هذه التكريت في المناطق التي سيطرت عليها
القوات الكرديه في سوريا عندما تسمع هذا
الخطاب من ضيفنا هل يتماشى تماما مع
الواقع الذي نراه في الارض السوريه
يعني خليني اقول اولا عن كركوك لماذا الان
رفع العلم سبق رفع العلم عمليات اغتيال
ومحاولات تطهير عرقي وكان الناس يعتقدون
انها
خطوات يعني حوادث خطا فرديه ولكن تبين
تماما انها توجد برفع العلم الدستور
العراقي يحدد صلاحيات الحكومه المحليه
ويحدد صلاحيات الحكومه المركزيه وكركوك
كانت تتبع الحكومه المركزيه بالنسبه
لسوريا منذ يوم يومين كان قائد كردي يتحدث
عن توجه الى ادلب بعد الرقه الاعلام
الكرديه مرفوعه الى جانب العلام الروسيه
الى جانب العلام الامريكيه عندما استقوى
الاكراد في سوريا اعني فصيل واحد حزب
طائفي عنصري عرقي ولد في رحم المخابرات
السوريه هو الجناح السوري لحزب العمال
الكردستاني هم الان يتحدثون عن ادلب ما هل
يوجد اكراد في ادلب يريد بدون سيطره على
ادلب على دير الزور على الرقه دفعوا حتى
الان 20 ال قتيل وسيدفعون 30,000 قتيل
دعني اتحول بسؤال اخير للاسف لان الوقت
لان الوقت بدا ينفد منا السيد رسول توسون
سيد رسول هل تملك تركيا ايه اوراق في ظل
هذا الموقف كما ذكرنا الامريكي المساند ل
الاكراد حتى انها حتى انه وصل حد التخلي
عن حليف مهم
كتركيا وباختصار لو
تكرمت ليس هناك خلاف بين تركيا وبين
الحكومه العراقيه وكذلك اقليم كردستان
انما الهواجس التي تدفع تركيا الى تلك
التصريحات ان حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي
الكردستاني معروف انه يحاول
تهميش اتراك التركمان والعرب ويعني تغيير
ديموغرافيه ديموغرافيه كركوك فكل فتنه
تنطلق في
العراق سوريا تتاثر تركيا منها تاثر قوي
جدا كما الان نحن نستضيف اكثر من 3ث
ملايين سوريين في تركيا ف بالنسبه
لعلاقات الامريكيه التركيا للاسف وكذلك
السوريا هذه الدول مع انها تدعي حلفاء لنا
الا انها تتعاون مع التنظيمات الارهابيه
مثل بياده الان القوات الكرديه انتم
سميتموها هذه ليست قوات كرديه هذه قوات
ارهابيه للاسف الولايات المتحده وروسيا
تتضامن معها
ليحتل لاحتلال على مناطق العرب وما الى
ذلك فلذلك تركيا تريد وحته الاراضي
السوريه وكذلك وحده الاراضي العراقيه حسب
الدستور الشرعي لديهم اشكرك جزي الشكر
رسول توسون النائب السابق في حزب العداله
والتنميه ضيفنا من اسطنبول كما نشكر جزيل
الشكر ضيفنا من لندن بسام جعار الكاتب
والاعلامي السوري المعارض ونشكر جزيل
الشكر ضيفنا من اربيل الدكتور ازاد علي
مدير مركز روداو للدراسات في الوقت الذي
ترددت فيه مفرد الوفاق والاستقرار في
ارجاء قمه البحر الميت ربيه وضعت انتقادات
وزير الخارجيه الليبي لموقف القاهره من
الاستقرار في بلاده تلك العناوين المنشوده
على المحك مفارقه يتوقف عندها محمود مراد
في الملف الثاني من الحصاد